hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is the
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 7
episode 4 the spoils of war this might
have been the greatest episode of Game
of Thrones I've ever seen it had
character reunion that had mystery it
had mythology it had an amazing battle
sequence seriously is every episode this
season going to kill off hundreds of
extras being I guess that's true all men
must die unless they're kind of
important anyway there's so much to
break down it's almost like a season
finale but in the middle of the season
so let's get started with the opening
images so right away we see the
victorious lannister and Harley armies
marching away from the defeated
Highgarden and we see what they're
carrying a scrooge mcduck quantity of
gold which the Lannisters plan to use to
pay their debts to the iron bank now
these are the spoils of this war which
is also this episode's title the spoils
for Royals refer to be valuable a
winning army loots from the losing side
and we see here in this scene with the
literal spoils of the Lannisters
defeating the Tyrells are but we don't
know yet what the spoil is saying about
the spoils of war until much later this
episode so I'll come back to that but
let's just say this isn't just the goal
that's critical to the Lannisters it's
the food - they're forcing all the
farmers in this area to hand it over
why are they doing that Jenny actually
brought this up in the first episode
that soldiers and horses need to eat
more the best fed army usually win also
remember they're bracing for a siege
from Daenerys and forces and at that
point they'll have limited access to
food supplies and yeah guys it's winter
everyone is stocking up on food and in
the long run food is going to be a much
more valuable resource to everybody than
Gold is now even though Jaime pays off
bran with this heavy bag of gold bran
still wants a castle of course back in
season five Jaime made this promise
tools you're going to come with me and
help me with something important and one
every time I'm going to give you a much
much ago and a much better castle also
notice how Jaime promises to reward run
after the war is won this is the same
kind of tease that Cersei just pulled on
your on last episode what you ha - hi
i'm alois of course this is exactly the
same kind of tease well who knows maybe
after the war bran will have his shot at
baby he's a handsome guy ok let's move
on to the red keep where Cersei is again
meeting with Ty Conan sores from the
iron bank
I notice how he said that why I always
considered your father a very effective
and efficient man but you appear to be
redefining those terms entirely now
Keiko isn't just talking about Thirsty's
efficiency at repaying the Crown's debt
he's also hinting at her efficiency and
wiping out all of her enemy now her
father Tywin said the bars pretty high
with the red wedding and that whole
rains of castamere incident and sack in
King's Landing the king whom he was the
hand of by the way but by blowing up the
Sept of Baelor
Cersei topped all of that and one stroke
she torched all of her enemies in King's
Landing simultaneously which was very
effective and very efficient
now when Cersei discusses the next step
she mentioned the golden company of
Essos so who are these guys and we've
actually heard the golden company
brought up on the show before in season
four by Sir Davos as a mercenary army
from SOS that Stannis can use to invade
Westeros 10,000 skilled soldiers fight
for the golden company the golden
company never broken a contract a sham
sure but the book goes into their
history a lot more see the golden
company was founded by a Targaryen
bastard 100 years before these events
man named Igor rivers aka bittersteel he
fled Westeros following the Blackfyre
rebellion and he first joined the second
son which was guarded harvests Elsword
army but then he decided that he could
create his own better company of
mercenaries so the golden company took
other runaway skilled fighters from
Westeros people kind of like Jorah
Mormont and then use them to sack cities
and SOS fight occasionally in rebellions
back in Westeros and now in the show
apparently helping the iron bank force
debtors to pay up then Cersei has this
cryptic line about her plans for the
golden company I too would like him to
recover some things that belong to me so
what is Thursday referring to here
actually have a few ideas
so let's activate query time okay Siri
won Cersei wants to recover Tyrion
remember he's the number one fugitives
that she still wants to get her hands on
he still blames them for Joffrey's death
and he actually did kill Tywin also it's
possible that she fears that he's part
of that bonk or prophecy to destroy her
so it's possible that she's sending the
golden company to Dragonstone or
wherever Tyrion his head is next in
order to capture him and bring him back
to her or ciri to Cersei wants to
recover
Casterly Rock remember it's her home
city where she probably has a lot of
fond memories growing up with Jamie and
doing all kinds of other stuff with
Jamie so now it's in the hands of the
unsullied so the ten thousand golden
company soldiers is just large enough to
take on the 8,000 unsullied which there
are probably less of now but then Seri 3
and this is my favorite theory
I think Cersei might want to recover the
gold that she's about to pay the iron
bank so stay with me here Cersei
agreeing to pay back the iron bank in
full now it seems a little out of
character for her right I think that
part of her feels like the soil that
she'd just won from Highgarden fili
along to her so why not use the golden
company to attack the city of Braavos
and destroy the iron bank and basically
take over financial control of the known
world now I'm not just pulling this out
of my ass look at the way she's acting
in this thing she's plain things close
to the chest she looks like she's
messing with Tycho's head also look
where she's standing between these two
pillars wine in hand looking out over
the map smiling and victory guys this is
the same framing as the day she blew up
excessive Bailey I really feel like
Cersei is planning something treacherous
here but while we're talking about this
shot composition there's actually
something even cooler happening with the
visuals so let's take this moment to
dive deep into the imagery of this
episode now if you notice it in this
scene but it's actually taking place in
the same room as Cersei and Tycho seeing
last episode do you see it's the same
desk with the same book and the same
candle and the same lion sigil that's in
the background but now everything has
been flipped the camera has literally
been moved to the opposite side of the
set and now puts Cersei on the right and
Keiko on the left this was obviously an
intentional move the crew had to break
down and reset up everything why do they
do this I think it's because Cersei has
literally turned the tables on Tycho
she has shifted the status so that now
he meekly follows behind her asking what
ventures he can help out with also
notice how last episode there was this
blinding bright light beaming through
the window
almost like an authoritative police
spotlight catching Turkey in the act but
now the lighting has changed to be dark
and murky almost like Cersei has dragged
I go down into the shadow now Circe's
treachery leads over from this scene to
the next one with Petyr Baelish
Littlefinger and bran which also has
some parallel interesting imagery just
like surtsey and Tycho's seems is also
in a location that we've seen before
it was probably brands chamber in
Winterfell where else would it be and if
you pay attention the visuals here this
is a recreation of the moment that
little fingers referring to the scene
where bran was attacked by the assassin
in season one notice how this moment
begins with this threatening tone to see
you by saying this is for you it's
almost like he's about to lunge out and
attack them meanwhile bran is totally
vulnerable covered in Wolfers just like
he was when he was under attack so I
think we're meant to feel like bran is
under this same threat again and little
fingers behind it so why does
Littlefinger give brand this pricey
Valyrian steel dagger that was used to
try to murder him now Sansa actually
indicates them later seeing that
Littlefinger clearly wants something
from brands the way Littlefinger is
talking here he's definitely playing the
role of like mom's new boyfriend and of
Yamada there's anything I could do for
you let me know I want to be there for
you you can call me Dad Littlefinger's
goal is to gain Brandt's trust probably
so that he can turn bran against his
sibling basically divide and conquer to
start children's by using brand to
undermine Sansa the way that he tried to
use Stan's it undermine John because he
could argue that bran is the true Lord
of Winterfell I think he wants to get
this young Lord under his wing the same
way he did with Robin Arryn
but bran isn't listening he's just
staring at his dagger and then there's
this exchange do you never just go home
to ensure it sings so it seems like the
show is reintroducing a mystery that
they left hanging back in season 1 of
who was really behind the hit on brand
now for everything going on with his
dagger Phillip and Maude actually went
into this mystery pretty in-depth in
Westeros weekly would definitely go
watch that I'm honestly more interested
in what Grant says after this yes now
notice how bran is looking straight down
the barrel of the lens of the camera
peering right into our soul freaking us
out the way he probably freaking out
little finger here reason freaks them
out is because this quote is from a
conversation Littlefinger had incited
with various back in season 3 in the red
piece thousands of miles away from where
bran was at the time
isn't a bit chaos is on lat
so if brand knows about that
conversation what else does he know
remember in that same conversation with
Varys Littlefinger hinted that a lot of
conspiring against the crown and what if
brands eavesdropping doesn't stop at
that conversation remember there was all
those little chats with Liza you gave me
those talk and told me to follow them
into Jon's wine my husband's wine you
told me to write a letter to cat telling
her it's a lunch also a bit more
recently in season 5 there was a little
deal he made with Cersei about Sansa no
no you're a man of your word and I see
it dog's head don't spike as I said I
live to serve yech Littlefinger clearly
has a lot of Secrets it's just
interesting that after preaching to
Sansa last episode about considering all
eventualities this was definitely not an
event allottee that Littlefinger
prepared for us now one last thought
about bran before we move on so it's how
Meera is upset with dr. Manhattan how he
won't show any real emotion or gratitude
for everything she's done for him and
she says most interesting line you died
in that case now I think this line could
have a deeper meaning and he'll why not
let's do a bonus theory time okay so
Meera is suggesting here that the branch
she knew died in that cave like bran has
never been the same but the bully bran
stark wasn't the only person to die in
that cave a lot of people did
specifically the previous period Raven
the old man next von Sydow now the books
imply that the old man in the tree might
be a character named the blood raises at
Brynden rivers another Targaryen bastard
during the Blackfyre rebellion he
actually fought against his bastard
brother a Gore River so I mentioned
earlier he's the founder of the golden
company but the show hasn't gotten into
that at all that they've left the
three-eyed Raven backstory more of a
mystery now why did they do this here's
I'm going with it I think that old man
could be brand years and years from now
in the future time traveling back to
himself in the present counseling
himself on the wars to come I mean that
would explain how he knew to bring him
back to Winterfell in his visions that
would also explain why the old man
seemed unable to walk really I think
and a three-eyed raven being one in the
same person would really be the most
effective and efficient way to close
this whole loop on this time travel
headache that the show could be setting
up anyway let me know your thoughts on
the theory down the comics okay moving
on to aria finally coming home to
Winterfell now remember last episode
another long lost art kid brand was
pretty easily recognizing at me trouble
getting into Winterfell but now Ari is
having trouble with these Winterfell
bouncers now why is that now at first I
thought this could be a reference to the
character Jane Poole from the book who's
also in the show but not as much now in
the book she becomes an impostor version
of Arya Stark that gets married off to
Ramsay Bolton pretty much stances
storyline in season five but the
creators of the show said that this
theme was inspired from Greek mythology
when the character Odysseus from The
Odyssey
after a long epic journey returns home
and no one recognizes him and actually
this isn't the first time Arya has taken
after this famous journey man and the
Odyssey Odysseus also tricks the Cyclops
by telling him that his name is nobody
or no one which is pretty much aria and
Jack Anna guards catchphrase and really
this whole idea that a long journey
changes the hero so much that he or she
looks physically different so that
they're a stranger to their own home is
what this is all about actually I think
this is another example of our theory
that aria is the stranger of the new
gods since her time with the faceless
men she has literally become no one a
face in the crowd we actually get
another reminder of arias past after she
Batman's away from these food dummies
down to the crib where she tells Sansa
about Eddard's grave it doesn't look
like him should have been caught by
someone who knew his face so yeah as a
former faceless man person aria is an
expert at recreating faces
that's where Walder Frey impression
spot-on even though she has a face that
no one will recognize now she's acutely
aware of what other people's faces
should look like now I got to point out
that all of these stark family reunions
that we've been waiting years and years
for they've all been pretty awkward
right like each returning stork has
changed so much from who they were last
season Jon reunited with Sansa after
getting stabbed to death and coming back
to life something that not enough people
are talking about honestly and these
characters don't even know yet that he
could technically be heir to the iron
growth now brand
come back as the three-eyed Raven he's a
warg and he can see through time and
there is no version of himself left
remaining and now Aria has come back as
this version of the stranger in a
faceless man she's still in this revenge
mission and she now has these like super
heroic fighting skills and she's a
master of disguise so compared to the
rest of her sibling Santa's journey
despite all the crazy turns it has taken
has been weirdly more normal than
everyone else's
then as Sansa tells Aria that bran is
home to notice that we hear a Raven CAW
as this scene transition to the
three-eyed Raven himself in the godswood
so just like he did with Littlefinger in
Sansa before bran now Luke's aria by
revealing something he could have no way
of knowing I talked to my coaches to
Columbus now this is interesting because
that's not just any moment arias
timeline and we're back in episode 2 of
this season Arya's decision at the end
of the crossroads was a symbolic
crossroads for her as a character bran
says here that he thought aria was
headed to King's Landing and he was
surprised to see her divert from that
path of vengeance to take another path
North home to Winterfell
so even though brand can see everything
it is still in pieces and I think the
only pieces that stand out to him right
now are the pivotal character defining
moments so looking back I don't think
that weird conversation with Sansa was
just random that was a key moment for
her development at the character then
notice that one brand gives
Littlefinger's Valyrian steel dagger to
Arya he says this line wasted him
equipped now this actually reminds me of
another moment that a crippled character
handed off a Valyrian steel weapon to
someone who might get more use out of it
Jaime giving his sword - Brienne now
Brienne named that sword both deeper to
represent her vow to Catelyn Stark to
protect her daughter's actually I think
that is why we see Brynn immediately
after this scene that starts together
and taking comfort in the fact that her
oath was cut by the way I just want to
point out that the show has been very
meticulous about tracking where each
Valyrian steel weapon is seems like they
want to make sure that when the time
comes to use these weapons they're all
in the right hand also I want to point
out that it's interesting both of these
characters brand and Jaime burned down
the super valuable weapons both of which
were historic relics from the war with
the five kings Royals if you will but I
have some interesting thoughts on that
that we'll get to at the end the video
and then
and as Littlefinger watches brand with
the sisters with suspicion there's
another Raven cough so even though
Littlefinger is watching brandy free
hydrated is watching him okay moving on
to Dragonstone and yeah this scene
between Daenerys and the sundae is
staged pretty much like a high school
rom-com now as they're gossiping about
the many things miss Sunday and grey
worm did there was like schoolgirls
clutching their book to their chest then
yeah when John shows up what great
standing is at the bottom of the steps
almost like Daenerys is being presented
on the prom date like and she's all that
or type annex I kind of was about prom
right when they gives Daenerys this look
like girl get it and then John takes
Daenerys on the perfect date that he
knows from Ygritte is a sure slam-dunk a
cave whoa boys sparks are flying guys
John is leading Daenerys by the arms
then things are getting hot and heavy as
they step into each other lit only by
the firelight and Daenerys is like on
your knee and then later sir Davos is
like man I noticed you checking out her
good heart okay looking past it hot aunt
nephew action which I don't know if
you've seen this but I'm going to leave
this clip right here notice that the
cave that John leaves dannion who is
actually the same one that she passed
right by on her arrival day at
Dragonstone first episode
Daenerys had her eyes so much on the
prize that she missed a huge
game-changer that was right under a note
okay so then once they get inside this
dragonglass cavern there are two huge
things that happen in the scene first
these walls are covered with these
ancient markings made by the children of
the forest and since I consider myself
an archaeologist flash action-hero
innovative Indiana Jones and Laura cross
let's look closely and decipher what
these images might need the new rock
stars favorite game of zoomit enhance
okay so these walls are covered in
circular shape some of which we've seen
before some of which are new some of
these are spirals some are the
traditional Archimedes
viral some are just concentric circles
that don't really connect there's also a
circle with a line drawn down to the
middle vertically and then there's this
whirl
viral pattern which Phillip actually
referred to as the octopus when it gets
mad the creators of the show said that
this cave is actually based on real-life
prehistoric caves in southern France
like in Lesko or Chauvet and they
singled out the specific symbol of the
spiral as an image that appears a lot in
real human ancient history specifically
some of these might be based on the
Triskelion which is a three branch
spiral that appeared in ancient Greece
and Sicily now of course we have seen
the White Walkers make similar patterns
in the past and season one and one the
first things they arranged sever to man
body parts wildly in this theme shape of
a circle with a line drawn through the
middle and remember in season three they
arranged severed horse parts in a whirl
angry octopus pattern always be honest
[Music]
now later in the series we learned that
that symbol might have originated with
the children before it remember the
stones at the weirwood tree where the
knight King was created were arranged in
the same spiral in fact in this scene
when John shows saneras the cave
drawings of the children and the first
men together we see the world spiral and
the bisected circle side-by-side so I'm
thinking that maybe these are the
symbols of the children before us and
the first men and that maybe that's why
we saw the White Walkers use those same
exact symbols it could have been doing
it as a warning against those particular
groups like men we're calling you out
we're using courts of you to do it now
one last Howard would like to point out
here are these comparatively super
detailed drawings of White Walkers to
enhance they even use different blue
paint for their eyes I mean this is
weird we just saw the doodles that they
did John are you sure you didn't draw
these yourself
also notice this white Walker drawing
this guy's wearing a crown so presumably
he's the night king but here he has this
beard now the night king we know doesn't
have a beard so what did he shave or was
there a different night king at some
point for maybe the children of the
forest mythologize is character the way
we do with Santa Claus like this white
bearded monster from the North who
steals your children anyway let me know
what you think down the comments okay
before I get to the second key detail on
the cave scene the reason we get to make
these videos because guys we can't do
this for free it's because our good
friends at audible are sponsoring it
audible offers a wide selection of
audiobooks and podcasts and you can get
a free audiobook with a 30-day trial by
going to audible.com/veritasium Ice and
Fire series inaudible I loved it I'm
actually currently listening to a knight
of the seven kingdoms which is a prequel
series taking place 100 years before the
Avesta Game of Thrones
it's awesome again just check out
audible.com slash new rock stars or
click on the link in the description to
start your trial today
ok back to this second interesting
moment in this cave notice how when
Daenerys asks John to bend the knee
again she uses a very interesting word
isn't best advisor more important so
just like how Littlefinger felt when
brand told him chaos is a ladder John
here is like whoa how did you know I
said that remember
John used those same words in season 5
to try to convince mance rayder to bend
the knee to Stannis Baratheon this
mystifies one pulling the yoke pride
right my pride so in that moment Matt
taught John that it isn't a matter of
pride to refuse to betray your values
and enlist your people in a Southerners
award the fact that Daenerys is still
demanding that John Neal shows him that
she's still fixated on the wrong war
okay so then outside after the merits
learns about Tyrion Casterly Rock plan
not quite working out she snaps
dissident enough with the clever plan so
this is a callback to the advice that
the late ulema tyrell gave are back in
episode 2 he looks have a man you'll
hand I've seen a great many gentlemen
how about Liv them all you know why I
thought way better gets back up to your
brooding Clips here in okay stopping
back in Winterfell we get this awesome
friendly fight between Arya and Brienne
notice how when Arya walks in brands
combat advice Roderick is interesting
third lunge Jake over your enemy leads
you and don't fight someone like her in
the first place if you think about it
this is wise war strategy advice that
also applies to Daenerys invasion plans
for Westeros don't lunge applied to
Daenerys making the first aggressive
lunge by trying to bring the Dornish
army up to siege King's Landing and that
confidence allowed your own flee to
ambush them second don't go where your
enemy leads view applies to Daenerys and
Tyrion sending the unsullied to Casterly
Rock which is exactly where Jamie was
leading them and three don't fight
someone like her in the first place this
is advice that Daenerys actually heed
she doesn't fight Cersei directly
instead she picks a fight that she can
win also I like how this fight
choreography between Aria and Brienne
matches the fight choreography between
Aria and Syrio Forel in season one we're
in like aria at that time uses broad
two-handed swings and lunges meanwhile
Aria like Serio now uses a more agile
fencing style
one-handed jab up and keeping the sword
behind her back so this is another
example of how much Aria has changed
remember in season 1 she desperately
wanted to train with a sword with all
the boys Winterfell but she wasn't
allowed to
look at the way she handles that bagger
all right that's leering seal are you
crazy
and then notice how Aria ends the thing
you taught students know now of course
in case you didn't notice that the
reference to I don't know I mean you get
what that's reference to right I don't
think you doing this every time now back
in Dragonstone and I love this little
exchange between John and Davos how many
men do we have in the north to fight ten
thousand less fewer this is Davos
remembering the recurring frustration of
grammar not the sanest Baratheon and as
foolish fingernails between Beulah next
enemies through you and then it's
interesting how a Sunday points out that
the concept of a bastard doesn't exist
in her home island north it kind of
feels like that scene in Episode two
when she's told this to Daenerys your
grace forgive me but your translation is
not quite accurate that man has no
gender in high Valyrian so the proper
translation for that prophecy would be
the prince or princess it was promised
we'll bring the drum so Miss Don day
here is helping our heroes realize that
these strict Westeros interpretations of
the titles don't really matter anymore
and there it can be a princess that was
promised and John doesn't have to carry
around the title of bastards I think
this is a key step in him accepting his
identity especially when he discovered
his true lineage and quickly when Seon
returns it's pretty nasty between him
and done and this bad blood went back
way further than Theon trying to take
over Winterfell and serving the Bolton's
remember in season one Theon was kind of
addicted Don and Winterfell Theon was a
board in the bastard Jon Snow was really
the only person that he can consider
lower than himself on the totem pole how
long's Yost no wonder okay here we go
moving on to the main sequence of this
episode guys maybe the best battle we've
ever seen on the show I mean at least up
there with that old bastard's heart home
in Blackwater this showdown between the
Lannister forces and Daenerys is
Dothraki horde and her dragon pays off
so many things we've been waiting to see
on the show
of course they dragon arriving to
Westeros mainland and laying waste to an
army but also we get to see some rocky
Horde in the action finally which
remember is something that Robert
Baratheon
warned thirsty against back in season
one only a fool would meet the Dothraki
in an open field and yeah pretty ironic
that now Cersei is that fool it's per
army that's losing here but I got to
point out my favorite shot of the
Dothraki several of them simultaneously
stepping up on their saddles and firing
arrows while on horseback now the crew
actually wanted an example of how
skilled the Dothraki were on horseback
and the stunt guys pulled us off with a
custom designed saddle with an extra
stirrup that they could balance on also
yeah let's face it guys we've never seen
the Lannisters lose this bad on screen
before since the show didn't really have
the budget to show every battle which
means we think it - see there lots of
the Whispering Woods now the director
this episode was Matt Shak man this is
the first stay in terms episode he's
actually directed and let's look at
these specific ways that he calls back
past famous battles on the show
okay so first notice how it has this low
bill begins quietly with a rumble in the
distance if you remember the battle at
hardhome began the same way and the
approaching enemy army gradually appears
in the form of a storm cloud looming
over the horizon just like it did in
Harlem this battle also does a really
good job looks point of view it depicts
this big messy melee through the eyes of
his key players so that we never lose
sight of where everyone is in fact it
uses the same style of a long fake
tracking shot with brawn scrambling in
the midst of the chaos just like a
similar shot of John in the melee of the
battle the bastards both shots even
include the same detail of a soldier
getting wiped out suddenly by a horse
and just like the Battle of Blackwater
this battle casts bran as the wild-card
specifically using artillery to change
the tides of the battle actually while
we're talking about that Blackwater
battle we should mention that that
battles gave groan is night title sir
Bronn of the Blackwater and that that
body of water is the same body of water
that this river leads into we're not
100% clear we're in the crown lands this
battles taking place but I'm pretty sure
this is Blackwater Rush and yeah these
terrific shots of soldiers on fire is
reminiscent of that same Battle of
Blackwater these characters are all
disgusted and freaked out the same way
that the Hound was and if you think
about it the Lannisters are kind of
paying their debt for the way that they
destroyed Stannis's men sure I guess
that doesn't apply to Tyrion Lannister
but hey at least he looks horrified at
cloaca be battle by the way notice how
the soul
are desperately trying to pull off their
armor that the metals gotten so hot it's
burning them this matches the way that
Daenerys described her ancestors dragons
and book she said that the dragon's
breath was so hot that it could melt a
nice armor and cook the man inside but
it's not just the ways that this battle
reminds us the past Game of Thrones
battles that makes it so great it's what
makes it different pacifically Shaq man
chooses to humanize both sides remember
with every other battle there was more
of a clear good side versus a bad side
even when the lines were less clear I
would say that on some level we wanted
Stannis and sleep - when it came flan
Denny more disappointing when it didn't
happen and I think we wanted Castle
black and the wall to survive in that
war against the wildlings and in this
battle even though it is pretty
satisfying to see demerits and drogon
burn the Lannister line this episode
does not make that easy to look at like
I don't know about you but I didn't want
to see Ron or drogon die and when Tyrion
was cursing under his breath as his
brother charged as American Grogan this
character is saying exactly what we're
saying a memo and this sequence actually
does a few key things to make us feel
this empathy one before battle they
include this scene between Jaime Bronn
and dickon's about how men defecate
themselves when they die so thick on
here is realizing that the whole idea of
bori of war is mixed this isn't a
spectacle these are real men suffering
horrible death
and then as the Dothraki cavalry charges
in jackman includes these close-ups of
Lannister soldiers literally trembling
with fear so just like that scene with
Arya and Ed Sheeran back in episode 1
this season is really trying to humanize
the Lannister truth by the way if you
are looking closely and I get to care
about baseball one of these Lannister
soldiers is a cameo Noah syndergaard
from the New York Mets and yeah this
sequence definitely emphasizes the
suffering of these soldiers more than
any battle we've seen specifically this
one close-up shows a deaf practice
sports of stomping into this ashy corpse
and then another shows the soldiers
ashes blowing away as if in a nuclear
blast this is normally the kind of
violence against the human body that we
only see enacted on reanimated corpses
but despite all this disaster unfolding
around them
Jamie and Ron act incredibly heroically
Ron saves the day by operating the
Skorpion which she's pretty darn
effective with and Jamie refuses to
abandon his men and he keeps enough of a
level head to rally archers against
Rogen and later to charge a Daenerys by
the way I think Jamie here is mentally
returning to that key moment that
defined him as the Kingslayer
when he stops and there's his father the
Mad King who wanted to on and on and now
jamie has seemed and there is burning
all of his men and he's desperate to
slay the mad Kings daughter the way he
did his father actually let's not forget
Jamie Lancer is one of the best jailers
in Westeros in the attorney of the hand
and book one he made it to the final
four of the joust after defeating his
Kingsguard commander Barristan Selmy and
when the Hound eventually beat him Ned
Stark observed sir Jaime Lannister
rolled in the dirt golden and dented
which is exactly how Jamie ends this
Jeff now sure Daenerys is heroic in
other ways specifically the fact that
she actually showed up in the saddle
which I'll admit is pretty bad add also
the fact that she needed John's advice
to mercifully not attack a city filled
with civilians and attack just the
soldiers and said but really guys let's
admit Jaime and Bronn are the Jon Snow's
of the saddle I want to point out how
there appears to be some real-life
cinematic influences on the sequence so
like the battle the bastard did this
episode seems to also draw on great
pitch field battles of film like
Braveheart Lord of the Rings and Akira
Kurosawa's ran but this beam also adds
another dimension to battle aerial fire
bombing from drogon and the shots of
drug on torching the Lannister supply
lines seem to be inspired by the napalm
bomb raid and Apocalypse Now and
actually the creators of the show
described Rogen as what it would be like
for an f-16 to be dropped in the middle
of a medieval battle and when bran
rotates on scorpion at first this kind
of looks like the Game of Thrones
version of a mounted gun turret kind of
like in Pearl Harbor or in Star Wars but
I think this is actually drawing from
one of the most famous man versus beast
panels in movie history
Joss so bran is a lot like the character
Quint
he's a salt of the earth badass who
croons these prat songs and notice how
in the scene there's a point of view
shot of
rogon within braun crosshairs that is
just like the shot of the shark in
quints harpoon gun crosshairs and just
like Brody does at the end of the movie
Ron get a clear shot that ends up taking
down the beat but just like how the
shark takes the boat down with him Rogen
takes out the Scorpion with flamethrower
and tail whip and like a Jaws the two
men end up in the water by the way I
think the shot of Jamie sinking away
from the camera with all of his limbs
stretched out is meant to parallel the
plunge that brand took when Jamie pushed
him out of the broken tower in the first
episodes the final element of the battle
that I really loved was the music
composer remains awadhi score was as
always a big part of this episode that
you might have noticed the House Stark
theme playing when Aria returned to
Winterfell and then again a few minutes
later when she smiles as a stark vigil
in the courtyard but here Joey does
something really interesting mixing the
House Targaryen theme which we hear as
drove on soars in and rain pail mixing
this with a darker version of the rains
of castamere remember the Lannister
victory song but now changed through the
tone of the music to a song of defeat we
hear this as Jaime fights hopelessly
through the chaos
then later at period and Jamie watched
their fellow Lannister men suffer
[Music]
okay wrapping us up here let's revisit
the title this episode these spoils of
war earlier I mentioned how the spoils
of war refer to valuables at a winning
army loose from the losing side in this
case the goal that the Lannisters looted
from Highgarden but when you think about
it that gold is really what dual Jaime
here right before this battle war Tarly
informed him that the gold made it to
King's Landing while the rest of the
line what's falling behind so
prioritizing the gold safe return load
this army down and end up leaving them
exposed you could argue that if Jaime
just sacked Highgarden and set up a base
there
Daenerys will be forced to attack a city
and harm innocent civilians which was
the same rationale that kept her from
attacking King's Landing but now
unfortunately because Cersei is embedded
the iron bank
Jaime had to grab the gold so this
episode as a whole is redefining the
spoils of war as bait in a track a shiny
treasure that tempts a soldiers greed
tricking him into pushing things a step
too far
so for example with Bronn even after
Jaime pays him handsomely with his heavy
bag of foil
bran gets greedy he still wants his
castle that was promised to us so he
sticks it out with the Lannister army
and suffers they're worse defeat
alongside them but then later bran drops
his bag of gold and rather than turning
around to get it he leaves it behind and
state rewards him it kind of like
wouldn't Indiana Jones always would give
up the treasure that he wants the most
while his enemies give in and the
treasure ends up destroying them the
spoil of war is a bait and trap
similarly in this episode brand receives
another spoil of war the expensive
dragon bone hilted Valyrian steel dagger
which Littlefinger explains is a relic
of the war the five kings but bran
wisely refuses this spoil of war not
taking the bait in the trap that
Littlefinger is setting forth Daenerys
refuses the bait as well the spoil of
war that she wants her hands on is the
Iron Throne which itself remember is
forged from foils of hundreds of wars
past in this episode Daenerys comes
closer than ever to just attacking
King's Landing outright but she listened
Superion and John and she denies herself
with foil for now and instead scores a
strategic victory that deny
as everyone else any physical foil
and that brings us to Jamie in these
closing images so last episode Elena
taunted Jamie for his past military
mistake the fateful foreshadowing of
this episode but she also left him this
warning about Cersei to be the entity
possibly yeah this episode shows how
fighting his sister's battle leads to
Jamie's downfall actually if you were
listening carefully back in the opening
images Bronn totally explained this all
very eloquently as he tends to do oh is
that why you're so [ __ ] boom all your
new riches weighing you down and now in
these closing images we see Jaime
Lannister golden invented literally
weighed down by his golden hand and his
golden armor while his character has
been weighed down by the spoils of war
do you think Jamie's a goner here
although what do you think Cersei wants
to recover using the golden company what
do you think about my theory about bran
being the same exact person as the old
version of the three-eyed raven and let
me know what you make of those markings
in the dragon stone cave you can also
tweet your thoughts directly to me at EA
box or to new rock stars at new rock
stars and definitely send us any
questions you have and if you do make
sure to include the hashtag Westeros
weekly so that Phillip modded me will
see it and maybe it will answer it and
what source weekly or in the breakdown
and of course share this video and
subscribe the new rock stars forum or
Game of Thrones videos and make sure to
check out our break downs episodes one
two and three and if you want to help us
expand this channel and do more videos
like this you can contribute to us on
patreon all right thanks for watching
see you next week bye